ciré et bas noir sont de règles pour une
fille et talon haut qui danse
aujourd'hui en ballerine pas de gant
vestige d'antique tradition beaucoup de
daim et de cuir en veste et en blouson
et jupes exige beaucoup de métrage en
ampleur mais peu en hauteur une règle
impérieuse gouverne la chevelure le
désordre est le fin du fin pour l'un
comme pour l'autre pas de chapeau bien
sûr mais le foulard des belles
négligenceces le poste à transistor est
à l'honneur car le goût de la musique
ravage les
foules on fume beaucoup dans ce monde
plein d'appétit des cigarette et
française de
préférence mais on mange vite et peu
sandwich et lait froid font facilement
un menu le cinéma est une nécessité
vitale et Brigitte bardau est son
prophète et on danse beaucoup pas la
Vals bien sûr Calypso ou cha cha cha le
téléphone est un besoin comme la
nourriture et la pensée il faut compter
diton une heure de téléphone par jour
lecture on lit encore Marcel prou mais
on abandonne le charmant prévt